استنفار دبلوماسي في شتى الدول الاثر
اشتباكات السودان
عمليات اجلاء الرعايه على قدم وساق
الولايات المتحده اجلت 100 شخص بثلاث
مروحيات حلقت من جيبوتي مرورا باثيوبيا
وصولا الى السودان
مسؤول السياسه الخارجيه والامنيه في
الاتحاد الاوروبي جوزيف بوريل قال ان اكثر
من الف رعايانا غادروا السودان فرنسا اجلت
ما يقارب
538 فردا بينهم اوروبيون وافارقه اما
ايطاليا فاغلقت سفارتها في الخرطوم وطلبت
من 200 شخص ترك الاراضي السودانيه في حين
تنتظر المانيا وصول طائره رابعه للاجلاء
مع ايصال 500 شخص الى بر الامان واجلت
طائره اسبانيه 100 شخص بينهم 30 اسبانيا
وسبعون من اوروبا وامريكا اللاتينيه
وايرلندا بواقع 150 شخصا كما تم اجلاء نحو
25 نمساويا
رومانيين وخمسه مجريين وواحد وعشرين
بلغاريا بمساعده دول اخرى
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات